we're overlooking Brown Sea Island she's
just there across the Solent there and
that is of course where the very first
scout camp was founded more than a
century ago by Robert baden-powell and
locals have turned out in force today
all of them telling us that it is
nobody's business what his views were in
the past they feel that that is ancient
history and they would rather remember
all of the good that he did fifty three
million people going through the
scouting movement globally earlier on I
spoke to some local residents here in
Poole and we can hear just how strongly
they feel about their statue on the key
here in Poole we feel very strongly
about this statue it is here and is in
that position for a reason
it faces Brown Sea Island which is where
the Scout movement was founded by baden
powell his history has nothing to do
with the removal of this statues he
wanted to stay there's nobody against it
they want it here a structure around it
to keep it safe what's the problem with
that there's no problem with that no
problem at all so what are they going to
do take the pyramids oh and Cleopatra
Snead okay so that gives you an idea of
just the strength of sentiment here in
Dorset today about this whole issue and
obviously this was on social media last
night some people have traveled from as
far away as South Wales earlier on a
spoke to some Scouts who had simply gone
on Facebook last night and felt that
they had to come down here today and
rally around baden-powell we can hear
from one of them now Matthew trot baton
pal was my hero I I think this is a very
symbolic item towards scouting it I
understand the need for to perhaps be
removed temporarily to protect it I
dried seen a box in the storage at the
moment than bombed the harbor but the
thought of it not returning to his
rightful place here on The Hobbit it
sickens me my core it makes me so angry
now the local council seemed to have
scored something of an own-goal really
today they sent out messages to the
media last night saying that this statue
would be
removed today for its own safety really
they don't want the situation where
people come here and put it in the sea
into the water as we saw in Bristol at
the weekend and they have no back track
though I've been told by the council
today that categorically the statue will
not be removed today quite well it's
future holds we don't know with the
council have told us on the record today
that they will not be removing it today
and certainly speaking to locals here
they wanted to stay here permanently
they point out it's been here 12 years
without a single complaint